Багато хто не уявляє Україну без сала, а Інна без цього продукту - взагалі не уявляє життя.
Зазвичай наш ранок починається зі швидких перекусів і для цього ми беремо… сало!
Найсмачніше сало у нас таке тоненьке, зі свіженького поросятка. Найкраще воно смакує з чорним хлібом і хроном.
У молодої жінки - чоловік і троє дітей. Усі разом за тиждень з’їдають кілограма з півтора домашнього сала. Купують його на ринку.
Рекомендована доза, до речі, 50 грамів на добу.
– Ви дотримуєтесь такої норми?
– Ні, я так не можу, мені треба більше!
Сало солене і мариноване, бутерброди, паштети, намазки. І "вишенька на торті" - сало в шоколаді. Інна ділиться улюбленим рецептом.
Нам потрібно сало, краще його взяти без прожилок, товщиною десь 3-4 сантиметри.
Відрізаємо нашу шкірку…
Далі порізати кубиками і в блендер із сіллю й перцем.
Потім сформувати кульки...
І потрібно буде хвилин на 20 до морозильної камери поставити, щоб вони застигли.
Заморожені кульки із сала занурити в топлений шоколад, дати застигнути, і - можна куштувати.
Реально не відчувається, що це сало. Такий наче… солоний шоколад темний. Дуже смачно.
Інна каже: сало й імунітет підтримує, і фігуру. От тільки останнім часом продукт стрімко дорожчає.
У минулому році можна було купити за 100 гривень - зараз 120, може бути 140. Дивлячись, яке сало, звідки приїхало.
За даними Держстату, за рік національний продукт подорожчав на 20 відсотків і нині коштує 90 гривень.
Фахівці у м’ясній галузі відзначають: стрімко злетіли ціни на сало в жовтні.
Водночас у соцмережах ширяться дописи про сало за космічними цінами - аж до півтисячі за кілограм!
Такі цифри - поодинокі винятки. Але в супермаркетах ціни дійсно вищі за офіційні: сало домашнє не дешевше 140 гривень,
солоне - по 200, а то й по 300 гривень за кілограм.
На оптових ринках теж нарікають на здорожчання.
Сало дуже подорожчало. М’ясо зараз дешевше.
Тим не менше, попит на сало залишається стабільним.
Найдорожче - генеральське сало - розмітають швидко.
Було 200-250, зараз уже 300, бачите? І це будній день, не базарний, у суботу-неділю буде ще дорожче. Будем бачити.
- А будете купувати, як іще дорожче буде?
- Доведеться, а як без сала? Трошки треба себе побалувати.
Хаобін бере звичайне домашнє сало. Каже, в нього на батьківщині - в Китаї - це найпопулярніший м’ясний продукт.
Якщо порівнювати з Китаєм, то залежно коли, але саме зараз в Китаї дешевша свинина.
Те, що продукти в Україні постійно дорожчають, - не нове.
Але чому злетіло в ціні звичне для українців сало, до того ж так стрімко?
Продавці кажуть - зросла ціна, за якою вони закуповують будь-яке м’ясо.
Корм подорожчав, все подорожчало, і електроенергія теж.
Постачальників сала останнім часом помітно поменшало. Великі ферми розводять м’ясні породи свиней.
А сало пропонують здебільшого лише домашні господарства. Такі як от у пана Миколи з села Митниця під Києвом.
У пана Миколи - троє дорослих в'єтнамських свиней і троє поросят. Усю ватагу треба годувати. Можна кукурудзою.
Оце така кукурудза, береш качанчик… і отак пішло...
Такий корм дістається господарям майже безкоштовно.
Треба лише позбирати на полі качани, які залишаються після збору врожаю комбайном.
А з них начистити кількасот кілограмів кукурудзи на зиму.
Пшениці берем менше, бо за пшеницю треба платити гроші. А кукурудза - втрати є, а в нас час є на пенсії.
Пшениця, тобто зерно, нині дороге, каже Микола. Зросли в ціні й інші корми.
При чому настільки, що вирощувати свиней на продаж селянам просто невигідно. Тому вони тримають їх усе менше.
У знайомої зі збору врожаю півтори тонни пішло. Півтори тонни - це 12 тисяч. За любого кабана ти 12 тисяч не візьмеш.
Як наслідок - поголів’я у приватному секторі скорочується, і державі доводиться більше купувати м'ясних продуктів у Європі,
де сільське господарство дотується державою.
За даними Асоціації "М’ясної галузі", в Україні обсяги імпорту свинини цьогоріч перевищили всі попередні роки.
Селяни, як і пан Микола, тримають господарство для себе. Але чимало хто нульової прибутковості й тяжкої праці не витримує.
Ми скоро корів і свиней будемо бачити лише в зоопарку. Раніше в кожній хаті було по корові, по дві, по три, а зараз - лише у сусідки і все.
Утім, вгору ідуть не лише ціни на м’ясо. Рекордсмени за минулий рік: соняшникова олія - плюс 57 відсотків до вартості.
І цукор - його ціна збільшилася майже на половину.
Економісти пояснюють це загальносвітовими тенденціями.
За даними ООН, ціни на продовольство у жовтні сягнули десятирічного максимуму.
Насамперед через інфляцію і логістичну кризу, спричинені пандемією.
Безумовно, локдаунні обмеження, які ввели і Україна, і всі країни світу, сприяють зростанню цін.
Але все ж таки ключовий фактор зростання - це саме збільшення собівартості через зростання цін і тарифів на енергоносії.
Енергоресурси займають від 5 до 25 відсотків собівартості залежно від типу виробництва.
Фахівці прогнозують, що в 2022 році ціни на продовольство й далі ростимуть через здорожчання добрив і морських товарних перевезень.
А також через зміну клімату, адже екстремальна погода для фермерів тепер не дивина.
Утім, нашу героїню Інну такі перспективи не засмучують - від улюблених делікатесів жінка відмовлятися не збирається.
На їжі економити не треба, бо зазвичай дешевша їжа - це гіршої якості їжа. А гірша якість на здоров’ї буде відображатися.
За даними Держстату, найбільше українці витрачають саме на продукти харчування - більше 40 відсотків доходів.
Для порівняння - німці витрачають на харчі лише 15 з половиною відсотків доходів.
І прогнози, на жаль, не втішні: зростання цін на продовольчі товари у світі ще більше позначиться на сімейних бюджетах українців.